first things first describe a perfect
romantic evening with Chuck without a
perfect romantic evening well you know
that that man I don't know how we're
gonna start with that
love them not a fighter really yeah so I
I like to surprise my wife dude I'm not
romantic at all shake your hand and say
hey how you doing
let's go for the room baby a bottle of
wine tons of chocolate and probably some
old fights get a little drunk eat a
little chocolate watch people beat the
[ __ ] out that is the coolest night ever
even got to Gatchell get a flaming yawn
strawberries you know life is coming in
with some lace panties my big one I grew
up with cats and then I became a puppy
guy later on my life I'll go up up I got
two cats so I guess our kitties team
[ __ ] over lie down and let them pile on
top they're like my kids are some type
right now he's got to be a kitty guy
what's your favorite kind of puppy great
question Beyonce Taylor Swift's oh god
Beyonce not a second thought I was
always a Beyonce guy but recently Taylor
Swift's kinda making a mark
Beyonce all day all day I like country
so Taylor Swift I'm gonna listen to
Nicki Minaj I don't know I learned about
truffle butter recently and it was gross
whoo Nicki Minaj song you don't want to
know about it tell me about well well
what's your favorite rom-com what was
that first of all what is a rom-com I
don't know what rom-com is what's your
favorite rom-com oh that's tough I
actually am oddly I like romantic
comedies
talk to you know what you're the only
person you knew what a rom-com meant
applause Iceman knows rom-coms guy the
movie where he gets the girl pregnant
and she hates it knocked up knocked up
that's there you go you've got mail
Sleepless in Seattle and no one would up
yeah yeah I guess we got white chicks
that's Katherine Heigl right that's a
really good learner fence a true rom-com
yeah she's all that what do you like
about that movie everything yeah
everything in a scene you have and
there's there's a residue trouble and
and then that comes out truffle butter I
just happened the damn edited version
goes rogue I'm not listening to that